origin stories Amazons and Nicholas Cage
there's a lot of things we'll never see
from these DC shows that got the ax
in the live action World DC hasn't had a
lot of luck with the Green Lantern first
off the film starring Ryan Reynolds
which was meant to kick-start the dceu
flopped at the box office making 219
million dollars from a 200 million
dollar budget then the attempt to
introduce the hero in the arrowverse was
largely a start stop Affair as the CW
never fully Unleashed John diggle as the
new Green Lantern there seemed to be
some Hope on the horizon though as the
arrow vs Mastermind Greg berlanti began
work on a Green Lantern TV series for
HBO Max in 2019 berlanti brought in Seth
Graham Smith as a writer and showrunner
for the series of course Graham Smith is
no novice to comic book adaptations
having written the story for the Lego
Batman movie The showrunner got to work
on the Green Lantern show and two leads
were cast in the shape of Finn whitrock
as Guy Gardner and Jeremy Irvine as Alan
Scott the show would have featured other
lanterns from the comics as well as an
entirely new Lantern Graham Smith
completed Eight Episodes for the season
in our October 2022 however a decision
was made to Pivot in a different
direction and make the show about Jon
Stewart the showrunner Departed the show
thereafter
the launch of HBO Max ushered in a wave
of excitement from DC fans as Warner
Brothers official streaming service part
of the grand plan was to utilize DC's
properties to create exclusive shows for
the platform in 2021 variety reported
that a Constantine series was being
developed by JJ Abrams and his Bad Robot
Productions company reportedly it would
have formed a part of the justice league
dark world that Abrams was set to build
out for HBO Max there were also rumors
floating around social media that gangs
of London star chopay durisu was in line
to portray the hellblazer on the show
however the actor told enemy that he
wasn't ever going to play Constantine
though stopped short of discussing if he
had been cast for another role in the
series in September 2022 something that
no one expected happened a sequel to the
2005 Constantine film was announced
according to variety Keanu Reeves would
return to portray the lead character on
the big screen simultaneously the film's
announcement also signaled the end for
HBO Max's Constantine series
gift John
one of the more interesting propositions
that was meant to debut on the DC
Universe streaming app was the show
called Metropolis the drama series was
meant to act as the Superman prequel
that would have followed Lex Luthor and
Lois Lane in the infamous city as they
explored the Mythos of this part of the
DC Universe the brains behind Metropolis
were John Stevens and Danny Cannon who
had been the executive producers on the
fox series Gotham 13 episodes were
ordered in 2018 with plans for the show
to air in 2019 however deadline later
reported that the show went into
Redevelopment later that year though The
Hollywood Reporter confirmed that the
show had been canned despite no official
announcement from DC about the Project's
status that said it's safe to say that
whichever incarnation of the series was
planned back then is all but dead in the
water now perhaps some of the ideas for
the show might be utilized for future
Superman adaptations
having debuted in Omega Med number three
it took Lobo 36 years to make his
live-action debut in the second season
of the Sci-Fi series Krypton the main
man is portrayed by Emmett J Scanlon who
embraced the character's wild nature and
won over many fans who had doubted his
casting at first however lobo's
appearance in Krypton was meant to serve
as a backdoor pilot for his own show
Scanlan had signed on to star in his own
solo series which would have featured
Krypton executive producer Cameron Welsh
being involved in the spin-off too
unfortunately the ratings for season 2
dropped dramatically and Krypton was
canceled the Lobo TV series ended up
being collateral damage in the process
as well in an interview with CBR Scanlan
reflected on playing Lobos saying the
character was the perfect merger of
Wolverine and the Joker he added how
thinking about the main man brings back
fond memories however he is disappointed
that his run ended so unexpectedly
bar
cool
Arrow birthed a number of other shows
such as the Flash and DC's Legends of
Tomorrow the season 8 episode titled
Green Arrow and the canaries was meant
to serve as a backdoor pilot for a
future spin-off series of the same name
on the CW the storyline was set in 2040
where Oliver Queen's daughter Mia takes
up the Green Arrow mantle and teams up
with Laura Lance and Dina Drake to take
down the Rogues in January 2021 the plug
was pulled on any potential Green Arrow
and the canary series as the CW decided
not to go ahead with it soon after Arrow
co-creator Mark Guggenheim revealed on
Twitter that the decision was largely
influenced by the effects of the
covid-19 pandemic Katie Cassidy wasn't
too Shattered by this turn of events
though as she explained to
comicbookmovie.com that the arrowverse
had been more than successful she said I
say this in the most respectful kind
realistic way we really really milked
that cow I don't think I've taken down
so many buildings at once
there's the reason the Titans TV series
doesn't have teen anywhere in its title
however there are many Teen Titans fans
who would love nothing more than to see
a live-action adaptation of the Beloved
youthful team and all their exuberance
and it almost happened before Titans
received the green light as reported by
variety TNT had planned to make a Teen
Titans show that centered around Dick
Grayson and his transition from Robin to
Nightwing in 2016 former TNT president
Kevin Riley announced the production had
been shelved and would not take flight
at all the Titans lived on though and
finally received their own show in 2018.
the CW's arrowverse proved that it
wasn't afraid to take risks on
relatively newer DC characters like
Naomi in fact there was even a plan to
create a Wonder Girl show about Yara
Flor the hero who is half Amazonian and
half Brazilian rain God Flora hadn't
even made her debut in DC Comics at the
time of this announcement in 2020 but
she had been deemed compelling and
interesting enough to get her own show
unfortunately it felt like the brakes
were pumped on the series before it had
even gotten out of first gear showrunner
and writer dalen Rodriguez broke the
news about the cancellation of Wonder
Girl on her Twitter account in February
2021. Yara floor went on to make her
official debut in Dark Knights death
metal number 7 which was released in
January 2021
for three seasons Hawk and Dove were an
important part of Titans as everyone's
favorite crime fighting couple after
Jason Todd clipped Hawks Wings Dove also
flooded away from the series actor Alan
Richton revealed to Entertainment Weekly
that it wasn't his decision to leave the
show but a choice made by the creative
team and producers who needed to cut
down the number of cast members
discussing his experience on Titans Rich
then shared some important details about
the characters of Hawk and Dove and how
they were originally supposed to feature
from the Inception he said my initial
deal was for two episodes and I had a
separate deal for a hawk and Dove
spin-off and when we shot those two
episodes they really enjoyed us as
Titans and invited us to join more
episodes in the back half of the first
season richson added he believed the
chances of a spin-off were always
unlikely if the characters were a core
part of the Titans team but he was told
that it would happen since they were so
popular on the show unfortunately the
spin-off never materialized
yeah you would have said not tonight
the superhero Static first catapulted
The public's attention with the release
of the static shock animated show
running for 52 episodes fans fell in
love with Virgil Hawkins and how he
balanced the crime-fighting life with
the trials and tribulations of being a
teenager the Goodwill of the series
resulted in many people wondering when a
live-action version of static would
debut in 2014 Warner Brothers unveiled a
new division called Blue Ribbon content
which would be responsible for creating
shows and cartoons for the studio one of
the first projects announced for this
Venture was a live action static shock
Show created by director writer and
producer Reginald hudlin a year later in
an interview with Flix in the City actor
Tyler James Williams suggested that
Jaden Smith had already been cast as the
lead for the show as interesting as the
show sounded it never seemed to go
anywhere the idea for the show appears
to have morphed into a film as it was
announced in March 2021 that hudlin and
Michael B Jordan would be producing a
live-action static shock movie
the superhero boom in the 2010s inspired
networks and Studios to get in on a
piece of the action considering the
success of the 70s Wonder Woman TV
series starring Linda Carter Executives
must have been salivating at the thought
of trying something similar in a more
lucrative modern era in 2011 a pilot for
a new potential show was produced which
starred Adrian Palicki as the titular
hero but it was never picked up a year
later vulture reported that the CW was
eyeing a series that would follow a
young Diana Prince before she became
Wonder Woman the working title for the
show was Amazon for a few years murmurs
about the project occasionally popped up
and the show remained a possibility
however it all went ice cold after the
confirmation that Gal Gadot would
portray Wonder Woman in the DC extended
Universe the CW's former CEO Mark
pedowitz revealed at the 2017 TV critics
Association that the network ceased all
plans to take a stab at Amazon after the
success of cadets Wonder Woman had ended
any chance of it ever happening he was
stronger than you believe
August 2022 was a tumultuous time for DC
fans as the new leadership of Warner
Brothers Discovery took the hammer to
various projects it all started with the
shocking cancellation of the Batgirl
movie but the Anthology series strange
Adventures was also revealed to be off
the table around this time however the
news of the show's cancellation was
actually broken by filmmaker Kevin Smith
on his podcast Hollywood Babylon Smith
explained he had been working on an
episode for the show that would have
featured Bizarro and Jimmy Olsen he
added that he was trying to secure
Nicholas Cage's services to portray
Bizarro which would have certainly been
a big get for the production The
Hollywood Reporter cited its own sources
that said the project had been silently
canned months before The wbdc Purge
in the world of comics Madame Xanadu is
a well-known and Powerful sorcerer in
the Mystic part of the DC Universe it
might have taken a while to happen but
the character eventually made her
live-action debut in 2019's Swamp Thing
TV show where she was portrayed by actor
Gerald Prescott while it would have made
sense to spin off the character from
that series into her own solo vehicle
the controversial acting of Swamp Thing
ended this iteration of madamex however
JJ Abrams and his production company Bad
Robot Productions had other ideas which
would have incorporated madamex into
their vision of DC shows on HBO Max
Abram's end goal was to create a justice
league dark franchise for the streamer
in which multiple characters would have
had their own programs one part of the
overall puzzle was a Madame X Series
that would have been helmed by writer
director and producer Angela Robinson
unfortunately the turbulence at Warner
Brothers Discovery and its upheaval of
DC programming in 2022 claimed yet
another victim in the shape of the
madamex show
[Music]